so there's been a lot of talk about this
travel ban judge overturned it said it
was unconstitutional I think we're not
banning enough since I got everybody's
attention here's some more countries I
think we should be first up Canada your
leaders too sexy no leader should be
that sexy Scotland bunch of men run
around in skirts sucking on a bag full
of pipes Italy spaghetti people next
Norway
I can't match all these go forward with
a J it's not built Ford Tough
China any country that thinks a cookie
can tell the future has no future in my
country you people are ban Japan now I
know that not all Japanese people are
robots but all robots are Japanese
people turkey that's food an animal at
best that's animal cruelty if you got
that many people standing on one turkey
France you and your flat pancake could
stay the heck out of my country yet call
them craps Australia I can't support a
society that supports animals with
pockets London people don't know Devin
Sweeney cookie in a biscuit if you can't
tell the difference between a cookie and
a biscuit you got no business come to my
country we meet to once will beach again
Transylvania I know thank you that's
where the mummies are from I don't need
any mummies coming here and stealing my
life grace I just an unattractive name
replace Bank Hawaii first state to turn
over the travel ban guess what maybe you
shouldn't come here either huh people go
down to a sleep 49 Finland on the
birthplace of Santa not a chance
you can't here trying to start from
Christmas again you think it's a
coincidence their capital is he'll sing
key he'll sing key he'll know Russia I'm
sorry they got all these tiny women a
little bit bigger women a little bit
bigger women how many women you have
inside of your women Russia Atlantis
people say it ain't real but I still
don't want no half-man half-fish looking
feller swimming up on my shores asking
for money
Iceland I've seen Game of Thrones those
ice walkers are creepy in fact they had
the right idea they built the wall South
Korea you and your sexy k-pop groups you
got all these days and Justin
Timberlake's dancing around trying to
confuse me I know who
I am and I don't like it I mean I don't
know I mean I don't like you you cannot
get it done Korea Poland no no like
their sausages no not like that not like
that no also one more thing about Canada
your socialist health care we don't need
that healthy people paying for sick
people that's crazy
look I'll pray for you I won't pay for
you thank you very much